gprenc dans un truc qui s'appelle qu'est
ce qu'on a fait à clavier dans l'écran
vont s'afficher des personnalités de
christian clavier connaît bien à chaque
fois il ya une anecdote qui
correspondent et qui a en commun avec
christian clavier alors j'ai aperçu des
coucougnettes d'un chef indien avec
christian c'est daniel auteuil ça c'est
à votre avis et qui
sait que je ne suis pas bon je
vais m'arrêter ou non mais je m'appelle
culture entre voit pas bien là on est
vissé dessus alors eh ben non alors tu
dis que sa ligne à l'automne ouais ouais
ouais mais non c'est jérôme commandeur
c'était sur baby sitting exact exact y
avait il y avait une scène avec des
indiens dans un film très bon bah tant
pis mais jérôme commandeur jacques de
l'âme aussi je lai un même on a pu
rénover un talent exceptionnel ou alors
sympathique habitants qui ont fait de
mon jeu en fait
[Musique]
c'est quoi cette histoire en fait non je
crois que j'aurais pensé que commandeur
et fab d'accord j'étais bourré à cause
de christian sait qui est votre avis
sur la chose non on va amener tous les
plats chauds non c'est pas fini
l'amérique joe webb frédéric chaussée
frédéric chau qui nous a dit ça baky
d'état ne vient pas du tout l'alcool
battue l'amie de l'alcool en fait dans
son verre non espèces dans une prison un
automne est donc on a même eu un petit
gnôle un petit peu fort
et là haut ce sont les amusements des
acteurs de béthune j'ai caché à python
sous de bungalows de question de la
shoah puis plh mais oui oui bah ça ça
crépite ont pu jouer à la wii sur baby
sitting deux jeux jeux une une bestia ce
couac on a remis après dans le genre
c'est là qu'ils auraient pu de bouffer
bah oui j'ai fait les unes hormis dans
le truck mois après parce que c'était
mon bungalow et mumbai à l'eau donc
comment tu te sens mal la nuit mais qui
est un bruit est ce que ça fait
[Rires]
tu fais plus tenir en u
c'était un très bel hôtel à trèbes et
locales au brésil c'est un souvenir
magnifique parce que c'est une bande de
timbre est complet des jeunes lève les
aime vraiment extraordinaire j'ai eu les
gérons avec ceux avec ce fait mais tu
fais hyper d'un python
jeu que j'aime bien les animaux je dois
dire j'aime bien il adore les animaux
question j'ai fait les poches de
christian sur un tournage au teil non
cane cane et guillaume canet il paraît
que c'est dans la soif de l'or entre
deux prises il aurait demandé à obtenir
un autographe de christian mais
christian lauret soupçonné de vouloir
lui faire les poches
il croise
alors
j'ai dû avait 17 ans il tient plus de
famille il a beaucoup plus d'argent que
moi
j'ai dû arrêter ma scène avec christian
à cause de deux filles ivres
s'inquiétèrent taille daniel auteuil
exactement c'était sur le film l'entente
cordiale avec deux jeunes anglaises il
nous a dit de
[Rires]
retourner dans ce pays oui je me suis
fait recaler un dîner avec question
rappelle di segni
question a refusé pour être certain
qu'il y avait bien sûr un surnom mais ça
c'était parce que c'est philippe même
quand on fait le premier bon vieux
moteur je lui racontais 20 fois donc il
me dit de malades et et gendrey mais bon
beaucoup beaucoup de rencontres et si on
avait déjeuné ans sur manille n'en est
pas question n'en est pas question on va
se rencontrer sur le tournage donc
j'arrive sur le tournage et ils sont
tous un peu inquiet et il voit arriver
de leur beau-père
et donc je suis assez froid
donc je vois timis est midi et au
maquillage et il me fait simplement
vous êtes très beau
on me dit saluer ce garçon est donc ça
nous a permis de faire la première scène
exactement avec le la whey
déconner on est devenus évidemment amis
mais si tu veux au lieu au lieu parce
qu'il voulait enlever leurs peurs elle
est extrêmement positive la peur et ça
me donne de l'adrénaline ça permet de
jouer deuxième leçon
tout à l'heure avec un
décolleté qui a récolté à m
[Rires]